so what in the interest of time I'm
going to move from that question to ask
where are we at manhattanville and what
could this group expect to be hearing
about manhattanville over the next year
or two I think it's important first to
start by telling you that manhattanville
is very real one great quality of
Columbia University we could say this
about any of its parts is its skepticism
we're great skeptics but I have to tell
you that that Columbia is real and
specifically Robert in response to your
question what that means is not only
have we I would say for the future of
the University have already secured the
zoning of the area so we have a right by
new york city zoning we have the right
to build 6.8 million square feet and if
we put that in the context of McVicar
for a second what's what's interesting
about mcvicar is not only we have a
great result we could have maybe have
you know we could have done a little bit
better we always feel we could do a
little bit better but we have a great
result in mcvicar the reality is the
university didn't need to seek anybody's
permission to deliver mcvicar yet we
were very involved in conversation with
our local community and what the
community basically did was said no to
what the original plan was from mcvicar
and that's in a relationship where we
don't need permission so if you bring
that to manhattanville and take a step
back and realize that what we did in
sort of one fell swoop even though it
took us two or three years to do that is
we've secured the right to build 6.8
million square feet really without any
further approvals required from the from
the city of the state and that that's a
pretty remarkable achievement so what is
going to happen over the course of the x
six or nine months in manhattanville and
if you have the chance to walk past
there at some point over the weekend
what you'll see is that work is already
underway we are in the ground literally
on Broadway and 129 street taking out
old utilities and
new utilities and you'll also see a lot
of sidewalk bridging so you know that
typical scaffolding that you see around
New York City we have that around a very
sizable portion of the first block of
development which is from one hundred
and thirtieth Street two hundred twenty
ninth street on broadway and then down a
hundred and twenty ninth street where it
intersects with one hundred and twenty
fifth street so the reason that Sidewalk
bridging is up is we're about to start
demolishing several buildings that are
on the first block so there's a very
tall white building hudson moving and
storage which we acquired within the
last 18 months from an owner who said
that that would never happen and she's
one of our best friends actually we
relocated her business to the east side
of broadway so her business continues to
operate in the neighborhood and we're
building a relocation site for her so
what will start to do over the next two
months is take down the facade of that
building and we're going to retain
elements of that facade and move them
onto a new building that will be
constructed very close to the medical
center so in very real ways despite the
you know despite our collective
skepticism the reality of manhattanville
is really upon us so streets are being
ripped up utilities being replaced and
the first phase of demolition will
happen during this academic year